thanks Brendon and thanks everyone for
coming even though it's very early on a
Sunday morning
so today actually my talk is gonna be a
little bit about a lot of the things
that I do so you might think come away
from this thinking I'm a totally random
crazy person even in a data science
context if you haven't already been
convinced of that from Brendan's
introduction so I'm actually going to be
talking about one of the biggest
problems that we have in data science
and it is basically to recruit data
science scientists and it's being hired
as data scientists from what I've heard
of conversations that I've had today my
slides are sort of a touch that link and
I'll show that at the end if people want
them but basically I wanted to
contextualize some of this in terms of
the way the some of the sort of jokey
funny ways that we think about the war
on talent and the sort of the comical
ways that we think about it and so you
know I am recruiter it's one of my
really liked loves of life and I love
this because we've all seen examples of
this kind of behavior in jobs and then
we see from especially founders of
startups with with posts about how the
war on talent war for talent Israel and
when you think about it from the other
side of it and we're very sort of
candidate focused even though we sell to
companies it's really not very much a
war on talent and so I think the I'm
developer posts from this sort of
Twitter thing she gives you a bit of
context of that is that this trying to
manage all of the many types of
requirements that people and companies
are frequently looking for within
budgets is it's a very difficult process
in calibrating those sorts of
requirements is actually very difficult
and so that's something that we think
about a lot of tap recruit so the
starting point of this is we sort of
come from a point that we think it's
very important what companies say to
talent say to candidates and that
actually really strongly influences the
candidate pools and the likelihood of
success in those in those processes and
these processes along they're expensive
and they're fraught with all sorts of
that in terms of inconsistencies and not
retry bust or reproducible and so our
goal is to bring data science and
decision science and very complex NLP
tools into that process and really
understand how we can make these
processes a lot more reproducible and so
the research that I do the group that I
run sort of takes us on in two different
ways the first is from a decision
science standpoint which is this
question of this well how do candidates
make decisions about which jobs to apply
to and from the one hand a lot of
companies think that because of things
like one click apply things like zip
recruiter have made it very and LinkedIn
have made it very easy for candidates to
apply to jobs and so the assumption
there is that candidates apply to any
job that they're remotely qualified for
but that's not actually what we see and
I'm gonna be talking a bit about that in
a couple of slides on when we talk about
some of these vignettes on the other
hand of thing on the other side of
things what we talk of what we think
about is how do hiring teams make
decisions about what a candidate's
qualifications are and how much how like
you know how much do they match for the
job and so you know you can imagine that
that comes in a whole range of different
things these are some toy examples or
toy examples of equations that might
sort of go into that process and from
the MLP and data science side one of the
big questions that I'm very interested
in and that is sort of an ongoing area
of research are like what are the
distinguishing characteristics of what
is a successful resume or a successful
job description or a successful
promotion package and the last part of
this is we sort of look at language and
skills and what I'm going to be talking
about at the end really quickly
hopefully are skills that are sort of
very qualitative science skills and how
they're spreading to other industries
and so we do a lot of skills mapping
because we have to do a lot of semantic
analysis to understand how those skills
are expressed in jobs and then translate
them into sort of large-scale trends
that we're looking at how does it
compare to in different industries or
different company types how to Fortune
500 companies talk about data science
skills versus for example unicorns or
startups and how does location factor
into that so you can imagine that
coastal companies talk very differently
to companies
Midwest about these sorts of skills and
so these are the sort of big picture
questions that I deal with on a daily
basis so we are actually not a research
company we are a commercial company and
we basically produce software products
that help use NLP to basically convert
unstructured career documents so these
are primarily natural language documents
into structured data and so these are
just wanted to give you a bit of a
context of how we think about the world
and how we connect all of these insights
and what's critical to this so that you
can have some context to some of the
research that I'm going to be presenting
so the first thing is a smart editor for
job descriptions and these are basically
and I'm gonna show you in a couple of
slides what that looks like but
essentially someone's typing out a job
description we start making suggestions
suggestions based on the language so
whether you're writing language that is
very unwelcoming or very full of
corporate cliches or grammatically
incorrect or gendered on one side or
will end the content so things like you
know are you asking for too many skills
or requirements and given the talent
market that you're sort of addressing
the second part of it is in terms of
pipeline health monitoring so that's
part of this whole idea of
evidence-based recruiting so what we
know is we have a whole lot of training
data that we know you know a job like
this should get this many candidates
this many female candidates in general
and how you going on those metrics are
you getting them fast enough are you
having issues getting your job
description out there where are the sort
of pipeline health issues and also to
analyze as people go through the process
what is your typical you know
qualification rate so like are you
getting a lot of qualified candidates
really not getting enough qualified
candidates and how can we help you
understand that process a little bit
better or whether that certain stages in
your pipeline process so when I'm
talking about a recruiting pipeline
we're going from everything from putting
out a job to analyze the like evaluating
the candidates and then you put them
through interviews and then you put them
through technical interviews are there
any steps of that process that seem to
be causing seem to be taking a long time
or causing candidates to fall out of the
process disproportionately so we sort of
provide a lot of analytics of companies
that we help and
the last thing is salary estimation and
this is something that is primarily were
using from a company perspective so
we're not helping candidates understand
salaries better what we're trying to do
is to be like tell companies look this
kind of combination of skills that
you're asking for this Unicorn that
you're asking for it's gonna cost you
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
a year you know that's the expected
salary for someone like this and it's
very rare and it probably would take you
six months maybe if we drop some of
these requirements you could probably
get there a little bit faster and so
this is just again a little bit of a
nudge to get people to sort of correctly
calibrated job descriptions and actually
it can work the other way so it's also
an idea the other sort of side of this
is you know frequently you'll see job
descriptions that are so vague that you
like is this an executive assistant role
or is this like a sort of very senior
role and so by estimating that salary
they can be like actually no this is a
much more senior role let's add some
qualifications to get it up to the right
sort of level that it should be so a lot
of our stuff is not too little nothing
much just getting the job calibrated to
the right context and so this is sort of
how it looks from a interaction
standpoint and what I want to highlight
here is that we have a lot of language
highlights in here where we identify
content that's missing so you know perks
and equal opportunity statements things
that are actually very important for
candidates which I'm going to show you
in a couple of seconds and also things
like qualifications so we understand
we've built very custom dependency
passes for understanding job language
and to be able to extract important
skills and so we know that you know if
this is a senior finance role analyst
role we can compare it to other jobs in
the same location we can also understand
what are the requirements that you're
asking for and how do they differ from
other jobs in the location so that's
what it contextualizes some of the
problems so in job descriptions and in
Korea language a lot of this natural
language processing and and really
skills generating it skills taxonomy has
been at the level of a title and this is
a very fraught process so as this
example shows two jobs that have the
same
title can be very very different but a
lot of the Korea tools that we use sort
of match on title and they match
salaries on title and everything gets
tied on title because it's assumed that
that's the major mechanism that's a key
differentiator but what we find is
actually it's more often wrong than
right and so it doesn't match skills and
experience and responsibilities and the
other part of what we do and because
we're able to extract the skills and the
requirements from these roles what this
allows us to do is to find similar jobs
that have very different titles that
would never have been picked up in any
other context and this allows us to do
some very rich analysis of the jobs and
also to sort of look at the language so
here I showed you know sequel verses
relational database we actually have
mechanisms of mapping semantically
different expressions of the same skill
set to each other which i think is
really very powerful in terms of what
we're able to do so I work primarily on
the research side of this but these are
tools that I get to use on my daily
basis to be able to aggregate similar
jobs and to understand what's the impact
of a title for example or what's the
impact of the way that you describe
certain types of skill sets and so this
is the last life and I'm gonna give you
a background of the kind of data that I
deal with on a day to day basis we have
15 million job descriptions and a whole
lot of their company verified salaries
and as a side note and this is almost in
its own talk of itself
we have candidate job search data
because for three years we were a job
search site for candidates and we sort
of pivoted to becoming a b2b offering
and so we've always kept that up and so
that's actually giving us rich insights
and I'm going to show you a little bit
about that later from a classification
standpoint and I'll talk a little bit
more classification at the end of my
talk we look at a lot of job categories
we have a lot of different
characteristics and these are things
like responsibility skills and education
and we also are an opinionated editor so
we give a lot of different unique sort
of highlights and we tell people no you
should write it this way based on the
research that we've found and so this is
actually the these sort of numbers sort
of give us the core of a job but we're
able to make very specific decisions so
the core of my talk is going to be
talking about three
keye hiring heuristics so things that we
tend to take for granted and I'm going
to debunk them that should not be a
surprise and so the first one that I'm
going to talk about is job titles so
there's a lot of different ideas about
what a job title is and what it means to
some people it's what's on your business
card to some people it's what's in your
email signature or your LinkedIn profile
but what I tend to argue and what we
tell companies is you know job titles
are actually really critical for
candidates finding jobs when they're
looking for a job that should be the
single most important thing that they
think about and it seems very obvious
but actually it has very dramatic
implications in terms of the candidate
polls that you get from these so the
context that I'm going to talk about is
the idea of title inflation and so we've
seen this is an analysis I'm going to
show you this little vignette of jobs
that are typically 2 to 3 it required 2
to 4 years worth of experience so no
more than 4 years worth of experience
and in data science what we've seen is
this massive growth of senior data
certain roles that are called senior
data scientist for people who don't have
a ton of experience and we're seeing
this tidal creep this sort of inflation
of titles coming earlier and earlier in
the pipeline so actually I'm actually
seen roles that are probably what you
would call an entry level or what we
call an entry level role so people with
no experience with studying to see two
or three percent which are called senior
data scientist roles right we don't see
the same in every industry suddenly in
software engineering we haven't seen as
much title creep so this is something
that's very big in data science there's
a lot of probably reasons for it but I
think the predominant reason is that
people think that you know normally you
have a normal set of applicants and we
have a data science role which is
relatively junior and you get a large
applicant pool and then you put them
through the hoops and the hoops that you
want them to jump through and you end up
with a few qualified candidates but the
idea behind this and the intuition
behind this is that if you put a senior
filter on you call a role a senior data
scientist role you probably attract a
slightly smaller candidate pool but you
get more qualified candidates so this is
a typical signal to noise ratio kind of
optimization that people think is
happening and one of the first things I
did when I first joined the company was
like is this really true because I'm
very curious because I would never even
after four years worth of experience
have applied to a senior data scientist
role and I wasn't sure that that was a
case for everyone and so what we find is
when we looked so the context of this is
in all of the next couple of slides we
took jobs that were similarly qualified
over the last couple of years and we had
one batch which were like data scientist
roles and we had paired jobs which were
called senior Danish scientist roles and
I could probably show you a few examples
because quite a few companies advertised
both and was sort of doing an a/b test
at the time I think
and while and those basically showed
what I'm going to show you so these were
all in tier 1 cities so that's so these
are New York San Francisco and you know
Los Angeles and DC to a certain extent
and so we restricted on sort of similar
skill sets so these are highly
controlled set of jobs basically that we
looked at the outcomes for and so
obviously when you add senior to the
role for the same kind of requirements
what we see is that the number of total
applicants goes down which is what we
would expect the actual average number
of qualified applicants is also slightly
more actually under the data scientist
role so I don't imagine that most
companies have looked at all hundred and
ten applications but they say they have
and so we have an actual increase in the
number of qualified roles and when I
found actually the most compelling from
this process is the last thing that we
look at is how successful is this
process and so typically for most data
scientist roles junior data scientist
roles which I'll call them that it's
about 60 to 70 percent of roles are
filled or completed there's a third of
them that are typically not filled
they typically just nothing happens and
then maybe the whole process starts
again and what we find is actually the
data scientist roles are much more
likely to be filled than the senior data
scientist role so the chance of success
at the end of this couple of month
process is double which is I think quite
striking it's telling us something about
number of applicants that we're getting
fewer qualified applicants and that this
is but based on the qualified applicants
the chance of success is actually quite
low so what as a scientist from a
previous life I'm very interested in
mechanisms and so I was very curious
what is causing this big difference
between data scientists and senior data
scientists and so one of the theories we
had was this idea of the confidence gap
and because you know I effect it you
know I probably wouldn't apply to and I
asked a bunch of friends and they said
yeah I probably wouldn't either and the
confidence gap is this idea that people
have different populations and this is
primarily thought of in gendered terms
but I think we're starting to come to an
understanding that it's a little bit
more complex than that but that you know
that there's a group of people that will
only apply to a job if they meet every
single requirement and then there's
other sets of people that might not even
if they don't need 50% of the
requirements they'll still apply and so
we thought okay well maybe this is like
making people feel like they have to you
know they haven't met all of the
requirements it's just that one single
name like it's not even a requirement
issue it's the fact that this is a
senior role so actually what we found
was because we were able to look at
candidates search data and the candidate
behavioral data when they look at it we
found that actually it's not all
explained by the confidence gap one part
of it is and I'm gonna talk a little bit
more about the confidence gaps in the
next slide but the actual interesting
thing was that this is this is very
obvious for anyone who works in
information extraction firstly senior
data scientist is a very rare search
term it's not very typical so if I were
a candidate right now looking for a role
and hoping that you know I would tend my
advice around because I'm telling
companies don't write Tait senior if
it's not a senior role well if you're a
candidate you're looking for the
arbitrage opportunity maybe you should
apply to these senior data scientist
roles that are quite junior because
they're not getting that many applicants
you're more likely to go through the
process but firstly it's a very rare
search term the second is actually from
search 101 if you think about search
algorithms when you start adding
unnecessary terms to the process it
doesn't rank as highly as the roles that
are called data scientists
and so I think this is this is something
that we definitely have seen that you
will see a few senior data scientist
roles come up in your search but it's
not nearly as much and so what we have
been able to do from extracting the
number of candidate click throughs and
the number of candidate views is to sort
of attribute some of this difference to
about half of this difference actually
to a visibility gap and that's actually
something that companies should think
about and that's something that I think
has a broader lesson to be learned if I
was to write a senior data set or data
scientist Washington DC that's also
going to do worse and search results
than it will if it's in the title right
rather than it would if it was in any
other part of the job description and so
those are things that companies should
think about and it's something that's an
arbitrage opportunity actually for
candidates if you want to find the jobs
that are less I could have come up on
search maybe you want to add some random
words in there and take a look at it so
the second part of what I was talking
about and alluding to was this idea of
the can of the confidence gap and so we
went back and looked at a number of
female candidates and what we see is not
only in the number of female candidates
but the proportion of female candidates
much lower with the senior data
scientist role and this is pretty
reproducible across it so this is just a
representative example what we also see
is that a number of qualified female
candidates is lower and the proportion
of hiring a female candidate is also
goes down so as this process goes along
but when you start off with a low base
you end up with much lower verses on the
data scientist role we end up holding
the proportion sort of across the board
so it sort of ends up with a more
representative chance so I would we
don't usually try and optimize for like
100 percent chance of a female high what
we want to see is something that more or
less represents what you get in is what
you get out and so this is again another
sort of example we've seen this also
with the instances that we have EEOC
data with minority candidates as well
but it's not as it's not as it's not as
complete a picture in this case because
we don't have a ton of that data so the
second part of what I wanted to talk
about is money
and obviously data scientists are all
about the money because it's the most
glamorous most highly paid job ever but
from this site I'm joking
from the standpoint of a lot of
recruiters one of the questions that
gets often asked is you know in in the
States and this is something that from
my background in Australia salaries are
frequently part of job descriptions or
salary ranges are included as part of
job descriptions but one of the things
that I was very curious about is how do
companies communicate whether they're a
very generous environment or not in the
context of job descriptions when
salaries are very rarely salary ranges
are very rarely included and so this is
something that I think from the
standpoint of companies companies
frequently think of how candidates
respond most to you know like a generous
company and so that that's the end of it
and so the sort of this is sort of
contextualized as some of the stuff that
I'm going to talk about in the next
couple of slides so I don't need to
explain any of this I'm actually going
to talk a little bit about competitive
salary in the next slide but it's it's
sort of a bit about the perks and
benefits because perks and benefits are
one of those soft ways that companies
can communicate culture as well as you
know their generosity and also you know
salary ranges can can also be sort of
communicated through that process so one
of the things that we saw when I first
started doing this work a couple of
years ago was that we started seeing
this thing called competitive salary
come up in a lot of different job
descriptions and so initially it was
very very low and I remember in 2017
where FS I was looking at it was sort of
spiking and so I kind of got my interest
and it was something that was talked
about a lot in startups so startups
would mention competitive salary because
it was one of you know they couldn't
really talk about you know they talked
about stock benefits and stock options
and things like that and then actually
now when we're talking about this
massive increase in competitive salary
it's not just startups that are talking
about it it's fortune 500 companies that
are talking about it it's I
big established companies that have now
adopted it as part of their lexicon of
job descriptions and so obviously the
first thing as a scientist I had to do
is check have salaries become more
competitive and there is no axes on this
because they really haven't become more
competitive if you look at BLS data or
any other form of data by city or
anything else and so real salaries
really remain steady but one thing that
was very interesting to us is when we
looked at the outcomes data when you
mention competitive salary it attracts a
lot fewer cup-like candidates and these
jobs take a lot longer to fill and
they're also less successful so what's
really nice is that we're dealing with
humans who are making mistakes all the
time and some jobs we have a lot of
paired jobs from this because sometimes
companies mentioned a competitive salary
but it's not part of their templates to
mention competitive salary so we have a
really robust sort of understanding of
this and so from a company standpoint it
was very strange to them and we were
like okay you shouldn't write
competitive salary and they're like no
but it means something good it's a you
know it's one of those good things that
people signal but actually from a
candidate standpoint and I think if you
think about it from a candidate
standpoint you're like actually that
sounds dodgy that sounds like a company
that's probably not gonna pay me very
well and so they're trying to signal
that they're not gonna pay me very well
and so this disconnect between what a
company thinks that they're doing in
that they're being very very pleasant
and really good between how candidates
in interpreting that is sort of the core
of what I really study and what I think
is really interesting and the basis of
out sort of software is to get them to
the same page so the second part of this
is you know pecs and benefits are really
critical and so the other way this plays
out is in terms of this disconnect again
between how candidates actually search
for a job which is on mobile which is on
you know apps through LinkedIn through
indeed through the sort of third party
into sort of like as in those
third-party software search platforms
versus how companies think candidates
search for for jobs which is they think
they go to their website and you're
sitting there and stalking them and
looking at all their amazing perks and
benefits before you decide to
to a job and so what is really
interesting is that we know that from a
whole range of research not only our
studies but others that perks and
benefits are really critical factors in
deciding on jobs it might not even be
the value of the perks and benefits it
could be the culture that it's actually
transmitting to the candidates but
what's interesting is that very few
companies mention perks and benefits in
their job descriptions so they have
beautiful websites that are you know
associated with it and that disconnect
between what candidates do versus what
companies expect them to do sort of
creates a bit of a gulf and so actually
we've always seen that startups have
generally had very have done a really
good job in terms of mentioning perks
and benefits because they know that
that's one of the few things like you
don't know a start-up in you know there
are very few startups that you do know
so it's one of the ways that they can
sort of get brand attention versus
unicorns and fortune 500s which are
actually increasingly mentioning perks
and benefits but not nearly as much and
so we wanted to drill down to see ok you
mentioned perks and benefits but which
ones are actually really important for
candidates and so you've seen a plethora
of these sorts of things in the Meuse
and various others its business journals
about you know all of these amazing
unique perks and benefits that attract
Millennials and things like that and and
what are the signaling impacts of that
but what we actually find is with
Millennials with middle-aged workers
with all sorts of workers actually it's
really not the unusual perks and
benefits that matter it's the things
like medical insurance 401k family leave
and actually the phrasing matters as
well so things like paid time off sort
of signals a very generous company it's
something that actually candidates value
so we've asked them to put an actual
dollar value on these things this is
something like unlimited vacation
unlimited vacation so it came out a
couple years ago when Netflix first
started I'm introducing it and it sort
of spread throughout the valley and a
lot of companies have adopted it that
phrasing and what that means to
candidates and we know now after a few
years that actually the companies that
offer unlimited vacation have very few
have workers that take a lot less
vacation and so it's not really worth
what it is but to a candidates actually
worth negative dollars so it's it's
one of those things that it sort of acts
as a deterrent but the phrasing actually
is really critical and there's a lot of
different ways to express this and that
express a different type of culture and
actually that's very important so the
last little sort of vignette that I want
to talk about is diversity and and how
this idea that it can be hacked because
we all love to hack various things and
so the context of this that I'm going to
talk about is the Rooney rule because
it's something that's become widely
adopted throughout tech and in a lot of
different industries so in 2003 the NFL
adopted the Rooney rule maybe you might
be familiar with that but out those of
you who on it's basically an idea that
when you interview for head coach
positions what happens is that you have
at least one minority candidate and this
sort of came as a result of the fact
that there were very few NFL head
coaches that were of african-american
and Hispanic descent given the huge
number of especially african-american
players in the NFL and it was very very
successful it's so successful than NFL
has adopted the Rooney rule in various
other stages of the process sort of
trying to increase the number of female
coaches through this process and like
Lessing new coaches through this process
and so it's been very very successful in
the NFL and that sort of caused it to 13
years later be adopted in big tech and
so you know Facebook Amazon pretty much
any and all of these big companies are
using the idea of the Rooney rule to
deal with you know board diversity and
also diversity on a micro level so by
micro level I mean all of the recruiting
decisions they're making on a frequently
daily basis the counter-argument to this
sort of came from a study that was
published in the Harvard Business Review
which I think is very interesting
because it highlights this idea that
having only one woman and they also did
the same for minority candidates in a
finalists pool actually doesn't they
have a very low chance of being hired
and so that has it's almost actually no
statistical I think the title of the
topic the title of the article with they
have no statistical chance of being hide
we haven't seen exactly this Barrett but
there definitely is that sort of trend
and I think the other thing that's very
important is that in terms of candidate
backlash that candidates are sort of
interpreting this as a sort of a sham of
a recruiting process I love these two
tech writers and amazing technologists
and I think they really do highlight the
sort of the tension in the Rooney rule
on on a sort of daily sort of recruiting
process so um how we went and tried to
find things that actually caused
reproducible you know improvements in
hiring especially in tech roles and I'm
going to show you the example of data
science roles because I think it was so
compelling to us when we looked at it
and what we did was we looked at the
number of we tried to find attributes
that were common to data science roles
that were successful versus not and one
of the things we found was that it was
it was kind of striking to me when I
mapped it when I looked at the
distribution of the jobs we looked at
the number of candidates that basically
was a very clearly bimodal distribution
there was one that sort of sent it or
maximized at 40 so we have the things
from like twenty to forty candidates and
then we had the ones that were more than
80 candidates and so these are sort of
representative examples what we found
was a 40 candidate pool for like a
junior data scientist role was was
really rather anemic it got as a
proportion as a raw number much fewer
female candidates and got fewer feet
qualified female candidates and the
chance of the female high was abysmal II
was very very low actually what we found
in contrasts was having about 100
candidates even if you didn't evaluate
them all was a much stronger pool
there's something about the health of
that pool that is a very clear indicator
and the number of qualified female
candidates and the chance of a qualified
female hire was sort of stayed even and
so this is what we say like in our
argument is generally the thing that is
very common to all of this is a large
candidate pool now I get a lot of
pushback from a lot of companies who are
like I don't want to have to screen
through a thousand candidates
it's very rare than anyone has to ever
screen through a thousand candidates
what we're talking about is a difference
between forty and a hundred and is also
actually the difference between running
a forty candidate pool process three
times
exhausting and getting really frustrated
job seekers who are like I keep replying
to this job and they don't really look
at me and they don't want to do anything
and it keeps coming up on my searches
versus a one shot where you're in three
months you can have go through that
whole process and actually finish it up
and and actually hopefully in two months
or one month actually get through the
process so so that's sort of the context
of what we think about the world so I'm
gonna just quickly wrap up this section
of it that I talked about job title
inflation and from a candidates
perspective the sort of looking at job
titles that are kind of unusual because
they tend to impact the visibility and
deal with confidence gasps I also talked
about how the fact is that we typically
think of being really what you'd call
like they promote interesting ideas
about like isn't that I'm blanking on
the word but it's the way that they're
sort of signaling benefits in good ways
are not as obvious as you think and then
the last idea that actually just
artificially inserting people into your
talent pipelines as a successful way to
improve female hires and what we find
with sourcing when we look at the
different types of sources that
candidates come from actually the most
important thing in our books and it's
reproducible is the representative
candidate polls because again these are
context where you actually have a
successful process so very quickly I'm
just going to talk about the skills side
of what I'm going to talk about so just
in terms of a quick vignette of this
because I've taken a little bit too much
time but the question that we have here
is this idea of what are the key what
how have data science skills changed
over time and we're not talking about a
time of 10 years we're talking about
literally 33 years and so how did we do
this
so to make a very long story short we
used word embeddings which are basically
distributional models that expressed
like the relationship of words to their
context so that's how I'm gonna really
condense a very large body of research
into this because I want to get through
and explain to you the context of this
so you know these are some examples of
you know phrases that we would typically
find in job descriptions relating to
Python and and when we do a low
dimensional reduction of this
sort of embedding what we see is that
you know the words that are closest to
it we get some context this is an
unsupervised method obviously largely so
you know we can get some context that
Python is a bit like Java and C++ and
it's probably a programming language and
if we add a broader context of other
words we can understand other sorts of
topic areas we can really get a sense of
the other languages and how do languages
fit in and sort of separate them through
learning and so this has been very
powerful from in terms of understanding
entity relationships and I'm gonna just
quickly go through this in terms of
understanding hierarchies comparatives
and superlatives and you know I think
the biggest magic has been in this like
woman to man and woman is to Queen as
madness - King which is my inversion of
what is typically thought of but I think
this raises so - sort of these highly
dimensional sort of embeddings have been
very interesting from a lot of different
perspectives but how they've been able
to be to draw sort of continuous
learning from them is a huge open
question and so when I'm talking about
connecting them over time there's
basically two mechanisms that you can do
this one of which is taking a whole
bunch training a whole bunch of
individual embeddings for different time
costs from different time points and
that requires you to use a lot of data
and firstly and it also requires you to
align them which you can do by hand and
what we did was we took in 2017 there
are a whole lot of papers that we're
talking about using the using time as a
sort of latent variable so we can then
connect them over course and we don't
need to it's basically one model to rule
them all in some senses and so I'm
actually not going to talk about what
the outputs of this are just by chance
because of some fun JSON rendering we
had - we ended up with a small corpus
and a large corpus actually small
interacts is a subset of a large corpus
and we're now obviously expanding this
to a much larger corpus we did this with
old job types we didn't restrict to just
data science - rolls because I wanted to
see how data science rolls how did it
data science skills that sort of come
infiltrating other sort of areas and
that we wouldn't normally think about so
that was sort of my intuition going into
the
and what I think is really interesting
about this is when you're generally
turning tuning training word embeddings
you typically take you know 300
dimension embedding and and train it
over time and we sort of did this with a
much smaller one and it actually worked
really well so this was a very small
number of documents over three years and
is also even our large corpus is a very
small number of documents over three
years and so what did this show the
first thing is that we saw the actually
the output of this is the to keep
drifting words and one of the key
drifting words is that MBAs and PhDs
across all jobs so remember this is all
jobs a falling and so we looked at MBAs
and PhDs obviously MBAs don't play an
important role in most data science
roles yet but we saw that actually the
number of data science jobs that are
requiring PhD is actually dropping kind
of significantly so this is over the
last Regas but especially over from 2017
to 2018 we've seen a big drop the second
thing is in terms of skills that are
showing significant shifts we're seeing
a huge increase in jobs that are
requiring DataViz skills especially a
power bi sort of started off of like I
said this is a little artificial in
terms of the plus 100% because it's
starting off a kind of small base one of
the key words that came out of our
analysis was Hadoop it was actually
probably in the top five it was is kind
of egregious how it came up and and
obviously you can see that Spock is
stayed steady Hadoop has fallen a lot in
terms of requirements of job
descriptions and that probably makes
sense because it's so easy to set up
AWS instances I wouldn't know how to set
up a Hadoop cluster but it's you know
these sorts of skills have become a lot
more democratized and in some senses as
these develop these things have
developed and lastly in terms of I mean
this was an obvious one I was actually
really happy to see Paul come out
because I expected it to not be that
critical but it's one of those phrases
that comes out of a lot of job
descriptions because you're talking
about scripting languages that are
important but obviously Python Estate's
steady and actually I expected it to
rise but it didn't and it was sort of an
interesting it's an area of research
that we're still looking at so the last
thing I wanted to talk about was this
job the large corpus and so what we see
is more Sandman
take shifts with this whereas before we
saw presence or absence of these skills
now we're seeing changes in requirements
so sequel was one of the top terms like
top five terms that came out of this
analysis and this is an analysis that
encompasses language as well it's not
just skills so I looked at sequel demand
and as a proportion of all jobs or
various other cuts of jobs and we didn't
see much of a difference really in terms
of sequel demand but what we did see and
this is probably the thing that I want
you to take away is that the sequel
requirement is actually increased in
very specific types of roles so we're
seeing it in FPAA roles so these are
finance roles in fact in your finance
sort of verticals of companies we're
seeing an increase in biz dev roles so
when companies are doing a lot of
analysis of their sort of flow and
actually from an HR perspective of
reasoning this a lot - as companies are
trying to build out people analytics
teams we're seeing a huge growth in
sequel requirements in hey Charles
so has stayed steady in a range of
others but this is sort of showing us
shifts that these verticals that we
don't think of typically in terms of
data science skills that you wouldn't
necessarily apply to as a data scientist
so I've got some interesting roles for
data analysts particularly and they've
got a very interesting growth sort of
trajectory ahead of them they're they're
sort of very cool so with that I know I
ran over time I just wanted to thank you
all and feel free to come up to me or
ask me any questions and LinkedIn
Twitter or anything else or even in
front of everyone so that would be great
thank you oh okay great
[Music]
you can take mine
maybe that one works oh yeah girlfriend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
have you seen or have any perspective on
sort of the diversity of roles that a
data scientist is playing and how that
relates to job titles at least I worked
as a consultant and joined a start-up
and we were debating what's my job title
be sure to be a data scientist should I
be a data engineer should be machine
learning engineer and quite frankly at a
four person company it just feels like
somewhat of an artificial distinction
because I'm doing a little bit of
everything at a start-up so does it
matter in terms of recruiting talent
particularly for a startup or does it
and like I imagine that role matters
more at a large company but there seems
to be a diverse array of terms that are
all sort of in the parent realm of data
science how do you see that playing out
and is it relevant for attracting
particular types of candidates I think I
think that's a great question I think
what we're seeing is we're seeing an
expansion of those roles so like machine
learning engineer wasn't really
something that was around a couple years
ago in any meaningful way so I think
actually you have two questions one of
which is in most companies what we're
seeing is that data science skills are
being taken up by specific verticals and
we're starting to see more data
scientists in like as in FPA or HR
people analytics person so they're
taking we're actually seeing a diversity
of roles that are more analytical in
focus and they're actually requiring
data science skills so modeling as well
as biz and things like that we are
seeing expansions in terms of machine
learning engineer like the titles of
machine learning and
I think they've actually changed though
because I thought one of the things that
would come out of this skills analysis
was we'd see huge amounts of machine
learning and deep learning real
quiet-like isn't in growth in that we
haven't actually seen a growth in that I
think it's changed much more subtly but
I haven't actually looked at the job
titles that associate with it we just
looked at the number of skills it does I
think we haven't looked at how machine
learning calling something a machine
learning engineer bus is like a software
engineer role that deals with some
machine learning impacts the candidate
pool and that's actually a very
interesting question I should actually
take a look at that but I think there's
a it's sort of it it does impact the
quality of your candidate pool one of
the things to be wary of and that we're
always conscious of is that we want to
make sure that you get a broad candidate
pool that isn't turned off by the title
so maybe machine learning engineer is
becoming a bit more comfortable for a
lot more people but I don't think it
used to be for a while and so it wasn't
a very popular term so those are the
sorts of things that we try and tell
people that you should try and be as
standard as possible be as descriptive
so that people know what you're coming
into one of the other areas I start just
talking to someone the other night is
from a software engineering standpoint
there's a lot of roles that are called
like software engineer internal tools
and those roles are actually very
typically very very much underperformed
in all of the analysis that we've done
because no one wants to work for the
internal tooling of a company right they
want to be in the business focused side
of things and so so that's sort of
attention that you know you have to at
the same time tell someone that that's
exactly what you'll be doing but that it
also impacts your candidate pull in a
dramatic way and so we're still trying
to figure out what's the best solution
to something like that that you know
gets to the right point but yeah I mean
I call myself a research scientist we're
not a huge group because I do a bit of
data science but I don't feel like I'm a
total I'm only a data scientist I do all
these other sorts of aspects of research
it's completely arbitrary and it's very
silly to call myself anything really in
such a small company but you know we do
it and so we can have email signatures
and and nice slides
oh hi
I wanted to know goodness if there was
the number of layers of vetting or the
number of interviews in the hiring
process had a significant impact on the
probability of a successful hire yeah so
the thing that we find is obviously a
lot of interview so we do count that a
lot of interviews do impact it but the
signal biggest impact one of the big
impacts especially from a candidate
perspective is a long process so even if
you have a lot of little bits to your
process if they're done in a condensed
fashion like within a few weeks it makes
it a lot of difference versus something
that takes two months as a process then
you get a lot more candidates just
pulling out of it and so we find that
actually it's the bigger like stretch of
time that impacts a candidate more
they've probably found another job at
that point or decided you know this
companies moving way too slow for me
like they're not my pace of things but
we we do do some of that analysis like
we look at assessments and things like
that as well like how are they impacting
that process but that's what we found us
on a big problem level that's the single
biggest impact is you know from stage to
stage how long it takes yeah
[Music]
can you talk about how it's possible to
kind of take a more holistic approach to
hiring a data scientist because you know
in my opinion it's more about building a
product than it is about like taking a
like a reductionist approach okay if you
know sequel if you know Python if you
know a scaler you know that makes you a
great data scientist word it doesn't
it's not you like it's it's a holistic
yeah thank ya what kind of analysis
could you do to address that um so I
mean we're a little bit opinionated
about this stuff I tend to tell what we
try and do is make the bar as low as
possible in terms of like stated
requirements but making sure that some
of them are required so like when I have
to create council data scientist for
example I'm like get sequel on your
resume like no one's asking you to do
really complex joints for the most part
but a lot of companies ask for sequel
and that's a huge barrier to like those
requirements act as barriers so it's a
very much a sort of like breaking down
the skills into the things that are
required and to get a sense of the
growth of that person so that's a hard
thing to explain in a job description
but that intuition can kind of be there
so maybe you don't need sequel like
maybe you don't care if like you
probably do need sequel from a
day-to-day basis maybe doesn't need to
be in the job description because you
know that someone can learn sequel
really quickly it's the era someone has
a growth mindset and they can learn so
part of that is sort of expressing that
you're coming from a growth mindset
company that you know you will
facilitate people to learn you know my
data engineer that I work with right now
has never dealt with data engineering
before we we tend to hire from very
unusual fields because I want to see the
transfer and I wanted to like isn't
someone who was really interested in
this sort of area and wants to learn and
so his background is a software
engineering back-end software engineer
and so that I think from that standpoint
it was very much a like expressing that
we wanted someone who wanted to learn
this stuff and I don't care if you don't
have that expertise but I want to see
that you have a history of learning new
things
so I think expressing that in a job
description which is a kind of very
esoteric totally abstract thing to
express but it's sort of drilling down
the requirements of what you actually
need and I needed someone who could
write beautiful code that has unit tests
and does all the right things that it's
supposed to but wants to learn this
other area that I think is you know like
cool and interesting and he thought it
was cool and interesting the other
people thought what's cool and
interesting so it's a little bit about
matching both of those things as to
pulling back on requirements in my mind
and and really trying to express it this
is a mindset this is a growth field
these are things that we will help you
do you know we will send you to
conferences we'll send you to PD like
find you courses to build up those skill
sets and really build you and invest in
you and I think that actually brings out
a lot of qualified candidates even if
they don't need to build those skills I
think that's something that gel is about
an environment that really values you as
a as a contributor or that we will set
aside 20% of a time to work on open
source things or whatever else like
there's ways and levers that you can
pull the communicator culture that I
think are very helpful in terms of a
holistic I hope that answers your
question I'm happy to talk about more
specific stuff as well hi
so I've seen personality tests and
problem-solving simulations as ways to
assess the soft skills of a potential
candidate hmm and I was just wondering
what your thoughts were on having these
tools combined with a AI to potentially
eventually replace HR managers do you
think that's gonna happen or do you
think that there's more of an art to
seeing if someone's like good at
teamwork for example yeah I haven't seen
the outcomes of a lot of those
personality tests and things like that I
know pie metrics is apparently a really
good job of like there's a bunch of
these sort of companies that do that
sort of thing
the one thing that I worry about with
tests is the sort of you don't know how
unbiased they are we don't know how fair
they are there's a lot of companies that
won't publish anything on like what they
get in versus what they get out and
until we start I mean this is me coming
from a scientist as a peer review
scientist to be like until I see the
data I don't really believe them
um so that's one aspect of it the other
aspect of it is I mean that's one thing
from like I said if you think about
technical jobs like data science jobs
software engineering jobs you know we
tend to believe a lot in tests and
whiteboard interviews and things like
that
I'm not sure how predictive they are yet
and so I think that's one aspect of the
questions that we really have to like as
companies need to invest in and ask
those questions the other side of it is
I'm not sure that those tests will ever
replace the soft side of HR or the
career documents side of HR and I'm
working for a company that's trying to
understand career documents so I should
really be worried about tests but the
thing is that the vast majority of jobs
are not as technical can't be you know
you can't figure out by test and as you
get more and more senior the managerial
side of things you can't assess those
through tests that's my personal opinion
right what you're very curious about
seeing and what I enjoy about career
documents is seeing how someone's
developed and the skills that they've
developed not only from an
anthropological standpoint or a
sociological standpoint but just from a
like the person who I want to work with
and that gives me a lot of insights into
it I'm not sure tests can actually ever
fully cover that sort of set of things
but I'm very curious to see how they
work like this is all still a budding
very interesting ecosystem that's got a
lot more to it than it is then we have
seen yet and so I think it's we'll see
how it bears out but I still think that
career documents so whether it's job
descriptions or your resumes or all the
other forms of documents that you put
together and you know your promotion
packages and and various other things
those are still gonna play important
roles we're still gonna have a lot of
soft decisions that we have to figure
out ways to diiie bias a little bit from
I'll got instincts and so I think that
that's a really interesting area of
research personally obviously I do
because it's alright work but I think
it's it's it still hasn't borne out
totally and those are the questions that
I'd want to ask them is that you know
how accurate are these sorts of soft
skills measures like they might give you
a number but like how much do you trust
that number and how predictive is it I
don't know
great I think that's all the time we
have
for questions but Miriam will be around
the rest of the day if you want to grab
her and discuss any any ideas you might
have so thank you and thank you Miriam
for the great present